over the past centuries technologies
have regularly come along that
completely change how we connect to each
other the printing press the telegraph
the telephone the newspaper the radio
the tv
all the technologies that begin social
revolutions
we're living through one such revolution
now it started in 1962 with a humble
almost boring idea connecting computers
together today almost three billion
people are connected but what kind of
revolution are we going through
well firstly it's fast it took 25 years
after the gutenberg press arrived for
the first english book to be printed in
its first 25 years the telephone reached
just 10 percent of america
in 1995 less than one percent of the
world's population was connected the
first billion was reached in 2005 the
second billion in 2010 and the third at
the end of 2014.
the benefits of the internet are obvious
in all around us in a european-wide poll
people put the internet at the top of
their list of daily essentials ahead of
the bath the car and the television but
the risks and dangers are less obvious
and more subterranean there are at least
four
one we're addicted in the uk two in five
of us recognize we're spending too long
on the internet but admit we can't stop
three and five of us check the internet
the first thing in the morning and the
last thing at night and put this habit
ahead of interpersonal communication
two in five women say that one of the
greatest challenges of relationships has
become how to prove more interesting
than the partner's smartphone nine out
of ten people would rather be surfing
the web rather than reading a book
internet pornography has proved
particularly compelling sixty percent of
u.s adult males admit to using it at
least once a month nine percent of males
classify themselves as spending between
10 and 20 hours a week on porn we're not
neurologically designed to withstand the
temptations on offer online and this
suits a great many internet companies
just fine
two we know too much but understand too
little the amount of information at our
fingertips is unimaginably large every
single minute of the day facebook users
share two and a half million pieces of
content twitter users tweet three
hundred thousand times youtube users
upload 72 hours of video 200 million
emails are sent and apple users download
50 000 apps between the dawn of
civilization in 2003 five exabytes of
data was created that much information
is now created every two days
there is so much data that we keep
having to come up with new words to
describe it the latest term is the
yottabyte this much data is overwhelming
and asphyxiating to maneuver we have to
rely on search engines google makes two
and a half billion searches per day but
we forget that these search engines are
mechanical and highly colored in their
interpretations for a start they
constantly direct our attention to their
products their sponsors and their
affiliates a lot of the information is
nonsense during the riots in london in
2011 the three most shared stories on
twitter were that the london eye was on
fire the army was on the streets and
that a tiger had escaped from london zoo
because the internet is often a source
of reliable information we exaggerate
its accuracy its importance and its
wisdom the twelfth most popular question
typed into google is what shall i do
with my life
it doesn't know but at the same time it
constantly gets in the way of the
conversations you might have with the
one person who does
namely you
three privacy is under threat
thousands of cookies track us wherever
we go our mobile phones log data about
our movements every five seconds even
when they're ostensibly off the head of
the french police force proposed it's
now almost impossible to commit a murder
and remain undetected we're constantly
leaving so-called digital breadcrumbs on
our online travels every year in the uk
we leave up to five thousand pounds
worth of data online which is then sold
to marketing companies and harvested
filtered and cross-referenced to provide
detailed insights into our lives
facebook will know you're gay long
before your mother does
seventy percent of us admit to fearing
how much we've already shared one in
seven teenagers in the us has sent a
compromising image over the internet and
had a sexual chat with a real life
stranger a majority of european internet
users are under the impression that a
security service has snooped into their
conversations and activities
4. online crime is out of control
over the last 20 years crime has abated
in many countries since it peaked in the
uk in 1995 it's fallen by 60 percent but
internet crime is exploding in 1990 the
nspcc estimated there were 7 000 known
images of child pornography at large
in 2014 american law enforcement found
42 million images on just one server
the uk government estimates that 50 000
people in the uk are actively involved
in downloading and sharing images of
child abuse online abuse and hate speech
are endemic on twitter 10 000 uses of
racist slur terms occur a day and 2 000
tweets are sent containing the word rape
69 of young people in the uk have
experienced cyber bullying the police
are overwhelmed the head of the uk's
national crime agency recently said that
they would only ever be able to focus on
less than one percent of all child porn
users
conclusion
one view is that new technologies have
always brought anxieties with them and
that they always turn out to be
groundless socrates in plato's phedris
warned that books would promote
forgetfulness people would become the
hearers of many things and will have
learned nothing
but that's too rosy and too relaxed
about what we're facing technologies can
and do bring serious lasting problems as
the residents of hiroshima realized the
internet presents unrivaled challenges
to our abilities to interact deeply with
our partners keep our critical faculties
alive stop thinking that the answers
always lie out there remain emotionally
connected to real life people and make
the discoveries that come when we're
bored and let our minds lie fallow we
need to start to take active measures to
educate our children in the dangers of
this tool to reconnect with the natural
world to talk to one another face to
face to stop downloading images of naked
people to get bored and to take regular
digital sabbaths we need to learn to
control ourselves not because the
internet is so bad but precisely because
it's so very very nice in ways that turn
out to be deeply detrimental to our
ability to flourish and to function
we can accept that it's not a good thing
to let a 15 year old boy have
unmonitored access to the internet in
his bedroom not because we think he's
wicked but because we're generous we
understand that asking for self-control
in those circumstances is too demanding
a similar argument applies if you happen
to be 26 or 46 the internet has an
unparalleled power to get in the way of
almost every other important and
precious thing around starting with the
rest of your life
you